good morning Hank it's Tuesday as you
can tell from the great speckled walls
behind me I have found myself in a
stunning turn of events in an airport
I've actually been stuck in the airport
for a couple hours Hank because my
flight is delayed and also because I
love airports but anyway heck I've been
thinking about the art assignment one
art assignment in particular Jase
Clayton's the quietest place for those
you who don't know the art assignments
of Cole show produced by PBS about
Contemporary Arts starring my wife and
to a much lesser extent myself JC's
assignment was for us to take a walk
until we found the quietest place within
walking distance right now I can hear
two separate TVs and some children and
quiet is an interesting thing to talk
about on YouTube because attention has
become so fractured on the internet that
there is no longer room in YouTube
videos for any silence I think I go back
and I watch our videos from 2007 with
the jump cuts that are really really
slow and the space between the jump cuts
is just absolutely unbearable
like in those three silent frames I
think to myself I might not survive
until the end of this video and in the
many hundreds of responses to Jase
Clayton's art assignment I saw this
again and again people would be walking
to their client as places as I am now
and they would talk the entire time it's
only getting louder this isn't working
at all the other thing I notice like is
that people's quietest places are
incredibly loud usually it was loud with
nature sounds which is fascinating
because it means on some level and I
think this is true we don't think of
nature sounds as being like sounds we
think of them as kind of a loud quiet no
this won't work I can still hear the TV
anyway I don't made me think about how
on the internet and maybe even outside
of it quiet can feel kind of discomfort
in just to get even through a few
seconds of quiet requires this intensity
of focus that we're not used to having
to summon you know who knows the
quietest place in an airport TSA
employees on a break okay and here we
are as far as I can tell the quietest
place in the entire Indianapolis
International Airport where by date a
for the carpet looks like this and now
Hank together we are going to enjoy
and/or suffer through a minute of
silence together alone with our thoughts
I can hear so much more than I could
when I sat down Hank happy hood gone
I'll see you on Friday